that's right t-shirt day why I'm gonna
get caged can you even see that Johnny
Cage t-shirt Mortal Kombat the movie not
the game or anything like that alright I
was hanging out at my brother's house
with a bunch of friends and we were just
hanging out and there was a cheese fest
going on in the background
seriously dude we had a cornucopia of
just cheesy shitty movies going on in
the background you know those ones that
everyone just you watch but you can't
turn away it's almost painful Mortal
Kombat one was not one of them the
movies that we were watching were much
worse however it kind of inspired me to
go you know what I should review some of
the older movies that aren't quite
Terminator 2 at all so give you guys
some reviews of some cheesefest starting
with Mortal Kombat which again is not
that bad or some normal combat the
movies based off of the videogame of
course the video game is huge in the mid
90s they were like if we're going to
make a movie about this and as far as
video game based movies go Mortal Kombat
ones one of the best if it's not the
best it's top - all right so Mortal
Kombat's pretty basic you know the plot
of the fighting game you know the plot
of the movie more or less there's a
tournament a bunch of people from out
world which is this other realm they're
going to invade the earth realm and take
it over and it's just going to be really
bad unless we win Mortal Kombat which is
a fighting tournament and I give this
movie that credit the video game is a
fighting game with a bunch of fighters
in a tournament the movie is a movie
with a bunch of fighters and characters
from the video game taking part in a
tournament that's how it should be it's
not like it was like Oh fighting game
alright let's have some weird hostage
situation go down
no there's different review for a
different time like I said cheese
cornucopia and although the plot of the
Mortal Kombat movie doesn't follow the
video game exactly you have the basic
premise that's a difficulty of taking a
fighting game like Mortal Kombat making
it a movie all of the characters are
actually really rich in story in the
movie you don't really get that you're
like oh you get some of the story for
some of the characters and for the most
part though they just kick ass and
that's that no in terms of the positive
of the Mortal Kombat movie there are a
couple of actors that played characters
they killed it as these characters no it
was not Connor MacLeod as Raiden first
of all the dude who plays Shang soon not
even going to try to pronounce his name
not going to try I can't pronounce
Killian Murphy right I'm not gonna try
that dude name this dude killed his
shank soon he was a perfect shank soon I
don't think they could have found a
better Shang Singh in the mid 90s or
even now I would have preferred old
Shang Singh in the first movie since you
know old Shang students in the first
game in this movie he's all young like
he is Mortal Kombat too but
more or less took the second Mortal
Kombat game and put it in the last 20
minutes of the movie 15 maybe that was a
bummer I didn't like that they did that
they really rushed through the last 20
minutes of this movie I mean Sonia gets
captured it goes up to the tower she's
like my friends will come and then these
monks take their hoods off and it's
Johnny Cage Liu Kang and katana they're
like we're already here I'm like oh well
I guess this is resolved now the events
in Mortal Kombat the movie could have
been broken up into two full movies the
second is K know this dude kills it as
Kaena like ice almond screen I was like
this guy is Cana I feel like every K
know that came in any game after this
first Mortal Kombat movie was based on
this dudes performance sad dude died of
a drug overdose as that was says sucked
but his legacy lives on as k now a toast
to the K knows other than that you have
a couple of cool fights too I mean
Johnny Cage vs scorpion that was a solid
fight Liu Kang vs reptile that was a
solid fight Goro's a little weird he's
his big animatronic dude in a suit is
alike
yes a little odd it was the 90s they
didn't have the CGI to pull off gore oh
you see that in reptile he looks
terrible the CGI reptile just looks
terrible so they were like god we need a
big dude in animatronic suit I would
have liked to have seen a really raw
Mortal Kombat that's like uh a subzero
ripped a spine out that's that's how it
goes down
but another target audience was
teenagers and teenagers wouldn't be able
to watch an r-rated movie without lying
to their parents and sneaking into movie
theaters it's Mortal Kombat great no no
it's not not at all don't think I'm
saying that I'm just saying it's
enjoyable if you're a Mortal Kombat fan
this is a Mortal Kombat movie made for
Mortal Kombat fans even though it
doesn't completely follow the Mortal
Kombat story it's not like you're gonna
be like oh I've never liked the Mortal
Kombat games the new game that generally
speaking kicks all sorts of ass I didn't
like that either but this Mortal Kombat
movie you know that brought me over to
the Mortal Kombat side I'm a fan now it
has never happened like that in the
history of mankind it's not going to
start now if you don't like Mortal
Kombat you're not going to like this
movie it's an indulgent piece of cheese
that I find enjoyment in because I'm a
Mortal Kombat van while I recognize that
it's a good time no alcohol required if
you're a Mortal Kombat fan otherwise if
you're drunk yeah no it's a Mortal
Kombat party it was way too enthusiastic
but I've said that while I've been drunk
and I'm just being honest so if you seen
the Mortal Kombat movie if not hey it's
okay it's okay
no one's gonna hate you for not watching
this movie I'm just wondering did you
enjoy it did you enjoy it if you're not
a Mortal Kombat fan I'm curious and
what's your favorite fight Mortal Kombat
the movie dude you got to go there
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more